So when this was first put together
here's an old cast of characters.
And there's two funny things for
me to tell you.
The first is, you talk about, you know,
missing a trademarking opportunity,
right?
So when Matt Turk and
Sandy Panaro were putting this together.
They had in mind this
notion of mug shot books.
You know, mug shots, where page through
this book of all these face images, and
you say, aha, that's the person.
So they were putting together something
that was going to be kind of like
a mug shot book, but of faces, and it
was going to be an electronic program.
So what do you think they called
this electronic program that was
supposed to be a book of faces?
Photo book [LAUGH].
So, you know, there you go Zuckerberg.
Hope you're happy.
Facebook was invented and
called photo book and so
then Facebook could be Facebook.
So that's humorous story number one.
Humorous story number two is
actually not humorous at all.
It actually speaks to, sort of,
the productivity of the media lab.
The vision and
modeling group at the time.
This, old cast of characters here,
bunch of these people were students,
in fact almost all of these people
here were students at the time.
Oh, and there's Mike Boe.
He was a research scientist.
But, some of you may
know Astand Sclaroff,
who was chair of,
Boston University Computer Science.
Well, that's him right there.
Some of you, ever heard of G Plus?
All right?
So Bradley Horowitz at Google was
instrumental in making that happen.
He's right there.
I think that's him or is that him?
Those two may be the same person.
Okay?
Anybody up in Berkley?
Trevor Darrell?
Computer vision researcher, or
here at Georgia Tech,
there's Professor Irfan Essa.
Neither he nor I look like we used to
look like when we were at the media lab
at the time but that really is him.
So it just tells you a little bit about
sort of the density of interesting
vision research going on at the time.
But basically what they did was produced
a database of eight thousand faces and
it was able to do recognition.